DANIEL FLORYAN: My thesis
work is broadly on fish
swimming and understanding
how fish swim well
and how they swim fast.
ALEXANDER SMITS: Daniel
is advised by myself
and also by Professor Rowley.
And he's essentially doing two
or at least twice as much work
as most people do for a thesis.
He's doing some very
interesting computational work
with Professor Rowley.
And he's doing the
experiments with me.
And it's a very symbiotic thing.
We're talking about
the same problem,
but we can ask
different questions
using these different tools.
CLARENCE ROWLEY: So Lex
is a very accomplished
experimentalist, and
I have some experience
with simulations and theory.
And this is a problem that
we'd already sort of agreed
to start working on.
And Daniel was a grad
student who came to us
and was interested
in this project.
So in some sense, it was
a natural collaboration.
DANIEL FLORYAN: So I
came in to Princeton
not knowing exactly what
I wanted to work on.
I knew that I wanted to work
on fluid mechanics broadly,
which is what my thesis is on.
And I knew that a
lot of the people who
work in the area of fluid
mechanics here are very good.
But I didn't have a
specific topic in mind.
So when I first came, I just
talked to all the people
who worked in fluid mechanics.
And after having some good
conversations with them,
I found two people who were
working on the same project,
actually.
And that was this
fish swimming project
that I'm working on now.
And it was something
that really struck me,
because more than anything else
it's sort of curiosity-driven,
and that's what
really stuck to me.
This is a computational
fluid dynamics simulation
of a virtual swimmer.
Because of the movement
of this airfoil,
it's pushing fluid out
faster in that direction,
accelerating in that direction.
And so the fluid pushes
back on the airfoil
and propels it in
the other direction.
So this is, again,
how swimming works.
ALEXANDER SMITS: So he's broken
that down into some very simple
models and then been
able to say something
about what nature
is trying to do,
but also how we might be able
to use that in an engineering
context.
DANIEL FLORYAN: It's
really validation
that I'm doing something
interesting, something
of value, something
that not just
myself but other people
also find interesting too.